Speaker 1: Saturday night. Trump Rally
in Warren, Michigan in support of Tudor,
Dixon and a number of other Republican candidates.
Trump dripping wet, afraid. We already talked
about that part. Let's look at some video of
the people who said, I'm going to go to this
rally. Here is a woman who claims to teach
economics. I don't know where her Ph.D. in
economics is from or anything. And she says she's
telling her students, and again, we don't know
where this is happening. To buy gold and silver.
Speaker 2: Ben And so I just really do my best in
regards to teaching them about economics,
showing them the value. Talking about
silver and gold and precious metals versus
investing in the stock market.
Speaker 1: No supply and demand
curves. None of that stuff. Gold coins.
Speaker 2: Because they say at the end of
the day, what would you rather have? And you're
saying, would you rather have gold and silver
dollar bills or sex certificates? What's going to
really give you that value that you can take home?
Speaker 1: You know, probably one of the most
cited economic scholars in the world. And it's
just my ignorance where I have not heard of
this woman again, unclear where she's teaching
economics. There was a guy at the Trump rally
who it's whenever they mention anyone who's gay,
like there's a comment about Marjorie
Taylor GREENE mentioned people that judge
and she just can't avoid a homophobic comment
when she mentions a gay person. Here is a guy
who mentions mentions Anderson Cooper and again,
like makes just a weird homophobic comment.
Speaker 6: First, prime minister in a Catholic
hardcore country and Sean was that much landslide
where he is all of them to be happy with
it right. Nothing. Zero zip silence. CNN,
they don't say anything. And what's his name?
Anderson Cooper. He's a gay. He's supposed to
support that known for women's rights.
Speaker 3: MALONEY Where is he?
Speaker 1: Anderson Cooper is a gay, as this
individual points out, and therefore, Anderson
Cooper should like the new radical neo fascist
prime minister of Italy because she's a woman
and gay men like women's rights. Quite a political
analysis from this gentleman. Really interesting.
He also later was interviewed
earlier, who knows earlier or later,
and said that Jared Kushner's ability
to solve problems is just incredible.
Speaker 6: Him and his Kushner, his son in law.
Amazing. This guy has a magic wand that can fix
it all. Yeah.
Speaker 1:
And remember, Jared Kushner was assigned by Trump
to solve the Israeli-Palestinian conflict. And,
you know, we all know how that turned out. One
woman that was interviewed by Real America's
Voice at the Trump rally over the weekend, she
threw herself at the mercy of the audience,
apologizing because she used to
be on the left. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: I wanted to apologize
to humanity for voting for the
anti-Christ. OBAMA So I deeply apologize.
I'm not Democrat. I was blue all my life.
Speaker 1: She was blue.
Speaker 2: I was also pro-choice
and I was an atheist until January 21st.
Speaker 1: And now she seems to have a
cross that she's wearing. So she went from being
an atheist to being a Christian.
Speaker 2: 2021 I had a sudden
awakening and it was it was absolutely
crazy. So I went from blue to red to
MAGA and I'm here and I absolutely love it.
Speaker 4: I want to tell you, you don't have
anything to apologize for. We all make mistakes in
our life, and that's where God's grace comes in.
Speaker 2: Biggest thing for me in the Lord it is.
Speaker 4: Oh, my gosh. That's amazing.
Speaker 2: Right? I wrote about it on my Substack.
Speaker 1: She's got a Substack Oh, beautiful.
Speaker 2: Would believe me. Except my
husband was there when it happened. It
happened so suddenly and so amazing.
Speaker 1: And it was almost like
a stroke. It happened so quickly.
Speaker 2: It was just like a switch was
turned off. There it is. A memory stuck was like
stuck into my brain. And I just started preaching
out of nowhere. It was the most insane thing.
Speaker 1: It sounds like it. It absolutely
sounds like it. That's very interesting.
Couple other clips here. Some people at
the Trump rally with the so-called election
integrity force who are trying to sign up
so-called Paul challengers to challenge votes.
Speaker 2: And part of what we're doing
is trying teaching classes and courses, trying
to credential as many poll challengers as we can.
Speaker 1: By the way, credential. It's
such a that's an interesting term for what
they're trying to do. Quite a credential they got.
Speaker 2: So are you signing up? Folks know that
if they want to be a poll challenger, they can.
Speaker 3: Yes, absolutely. You can go
to M.C. for ICOM or election
integrity for dot com and sign
up to be a poll challenging volunteer. We
are credentialing people all over the state
so you don't have to be here in McComb or.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's quite a credentialing
body that this guy is doing. Okay.
And then lastly, here's a woman who
loves that. The Republican candidate, Tudor
Dixon for governor in Michigan is completely
against all abortion. This woman loves it.
Speaker 2: If she got molested by a family member,
she would keep her child. I'm on my way to her.
I would keep mine through. So please vote, not.
Speaker 3: Vote for Twitter. Give up on Twitter.
Speaker 2: Because she's saying she does not want
abortions in Michigan, is under no exemptions.
I'm willing to go even a little bit extra on say
that me and Tudor, we will have discussions
and I will be sitting with her and we will
make a way because this is the way we will do.
Planned Parenthood should be working vigorously.
Speaker 3: And efforts lead
for those abortion laws, not.
Speaker 2: To honor Dixon. They should get
moneys for these women. If abortions won't
be in Michigan, then fly those women somewhere
and get them some help. Because, no, I do have
sympathy for people who was raped and incest. But
Planned Parenthood should get money and send these
women to another outside state. That's close.
Speaker 1: Okay. So I guess what she's saying is
she's against any exceptions for rape and
incest, but she's empathetic to people to
whom that happens, but fly them to a different
state. That's very weird and extraordinarily
scrambled. But it is what it is. Scary stuff
at the Trump rally. And we will have all of
these clips on our Instagram, which you
can find at David Pakman show. All right.